hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
in certain corners of the internet
certainly ones that i find myself in all
the time there's a saying that goes
there's an xkcd for everything
xkcd of course is the wildly popular web
comic started in 2005 by today's guest
randall monroe and xkcd is famous for
many things it has a very austere
minimalist art style featuring
more or less stick figures doing things
and very often just talking to each
other but there's also a spirit about it
that is very very resonant with people
who care about science and technology
and building things and numbers and
lists and words but also who understand
that these things are connected to
humanity and love and emotions and
things like that it's also remarkably
good at finding those little things that
you've been thinking about and turning
them into webcomic form thus the idea
that there really is an xkcd out there
for everything
one of the very popular features of the
blog that randall runs associated with
xkcd is the what-if section where he
started a few years ago taking questions
from readers about you know what if this
crazy hypothetical scenario was going on
something that he himself is very fond
of doing this is the origin of probably
many of the comics and the great thing
about the what if questions is that it's
not just a yes or no answer and you have
to
really think sometimes you know the the
questions being asked the famous the
iconic what if question is what if
someone pitched a baseball at 99.999
percent the speed of light what would it
do when you tried to hit it
you got you have to take that seriously
right you know okay what would it mean
to move at that speed through the
atmosphere and you have to
ignore the problems like you cannot
throw a baseball that fast and take
seriously the consequences and
what randall has subsequently done is to
collect some of the best answers to the
what if questions into a book first
called what if serious scientific
answers to absurd hypothetical questions
and now just very recently what if two
additional serious scientific answers to
absurd hypothetical questions and what i
love about the book is that you really
learn a lot by reading it not just
because he gives you the answers but
because he walks you through the
methodology for answering these
questions and of course it's sprinkled
with humor and cute little cartoons
along the way uh randall really has an
amazing capacity to think about things
in a new and enlightening illuminating
way and so it's been great to talk to
him we're going to talk a little bit
about some crazy hypothetical questions
and a little bit about the general
strategy for addressing such questions
and why
it's so interesting to do so so let's go
[Music]
randall monroe welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks it's so great to be here
so you have a famous comic strip
obviously famous webcomic but the
immediate reason that i was able to get
you on the show here is because you have
a new book coming out so i do want to
talk about the book because the more i
think about it it's just a kind of a
fascinating concept and you're clearly
having a lot of fun with it so why don't
you tell the audience about what if and
its successor what if two and uh why why
this is a good thing to do and buy a
book about
well i originally started off drawing
comics about science and you know
because i touched on these subjects of
of like weird science ideas i found
people would often write to me with
questions to answer which i was not
expecting
um and often
it wouldn't just be that they had their
question they thought i was the best
person to answer it there was sort of an
undertone of like it was like a
backhanded compliment they were like me
and my friend have been arguing over
this science question but we don't think
it's a good enough question like
important enough question to bother like
a real scientist with we all agreed you
seemed like a good person to talk to you
have nothing else to do
yeah he he probably that guy who does
the comics he he's not a real scientist
he can bother him
um and so
i uh but the thing is they were right
like i i
[Music]
so i would spend um you know i would get
an email with some question about
superman or you know building tall
skyscrapers or dropping things off of
other things or lava
and
i would see the question and then like
it's like you know one of those things
where you you briefly black out in like
six hours have passed and you're i would
have like you know 500 tabs open and
like 80 pdfs and like
um uh books that i dug out of the closet
or
and
because i'm just determined to know like
all right once i've seen the question i
want to know the answer yeah
and so i would send them all this work i
had done and at some point i was like
i'm putting a lot of work into these
emails which are probably half them
getting spam filtered like i should
share some of this research because i'm
learning all this cool stuff
and so i started um uh posting them
online and eventually uh publishing them
as a book first what if and then
that
the problem with publishing those is it
only leads to more questions of course
uh just asking for so then
and so now uh what if too
and it's like my compiled answers to
these questions that random people have
sent me so to give the audience who
unfortunately has not read what if one a
flavor for what's going on here just
tell us one or two of your favorite
questions that you've answered
uh well i mean the one that i the one
that i that it sort of all started with
was
what would happen if you tried to hit a
baseball that was pitched at 90 of the
speed of light
and um
and it's fun because the
i like questions where you're like well
right away i know nothing good is going
to happen there that's not good right
but
i'm not actually sure what would happen
and that was the case you know i ended
up having to spend uh uh
you know six hours just going through
sort of the particle physics of like the
ball would start crashing into the air
in front of it
and you know might undergo nuclear
fusion
how many of the air molecules would pass
directly through the ball how many would
fuse what would they release
and you end up with this sort of
millisecond or nanosecond by nanosecond
picture of like the ball disintegrating
into an expanding cloud of radiation and
destroying the uh
the playing field
presumably yeah the the kinetic energy
is large enough that the explosion is
going to be pretty big or is it mostly
from
because there's no antimatter is running
into with there wouldn't be a lot of
conversion into actual pure energy it's
just the kinetic energy right yeah it's
well it's the kinetic energy you do get
quite a bit from fusion though for
fusion
because the ball is going fast and it's
actually going fast enough i got a great
content uh i got uh
some folks from an mit high energy
laboratory after i published the first
book who um
said you know hey we we saw your
question and we loved this so we ran the
i ran the simulation uh of those impacts
and here's how the actual you know
energy distribution worked out which was
cool i got then i got the software and i
got to run it myself
um
but uh uh
it it's fun because like it's fun to get
specific um my favorite thing about that
scenario is
that the um that the ball is approaching
the batter
but it's um
moving at near the speed of light
which means the batter like
doesn't have any sign that it's coming
until the first wave of radiation hits
and
and once it does
the speed at which signals move down the
optic nerve
is slower than the rate at which the you
know the actual cloud of the ball
approaches and starts disintegrating you
so you would literally not see what hit
you
it's interesting to me because there's a
lot of
steps in the thought process at which
many people might say well no this is
just not going to happen so i'm not
going to follow it up like i could say
no you can't throw a ball at the 0.9 of
the speed of light or you know it what
would happen is it would go by the
person so quickly but the
taking into account exactly the right
level of detail seems to be part of the
art form here right like just say it's
going 0.9 of the speed of light but
don't ignore air resistance right these
are very explicit choices along the way
yeah yeah and the way i usually think
about these is like we're not going to
worry about how the situation got set up
exactly like
the the the premise is what if like what
if somehow
this situation occurred
and then you like press play on it and
let normal physics take over
um
and so often people would would
kind of design questions
trying to elicit really destructive uh
results
you know you'll so so i found that
people
who liked the questions in the first
book you know would send in things like
um
well what if i put a nuclear bomb on a
train that was going at relativistic
speeds but through a tunnel so that it
doesn't interact with the air and then
it's going toward a volcano or something
um
and this is where i found that like
little kids asked some of the best
questions
because little kids aren't trying to
come up with something weird they're
just like asking an actual question that
they're curious about right
and
that was like one of my favorite ones in
um
in what if two is a little girl who
asked uh what if i wanted a billion
story building
and she like asked her dad and he
couldn't answer it so he sent it to me
he was like you know i don't really know
what gets in your way if you do that
and what's funny is it's like it's a
much more concrete question it's like a
straightforward real question and the
answer turns out to actually be more
destructive than the train thing
oh really well go ahead tell us the
answer don't hold us in well like like a
billion stories is you know really
really really tall there's a
the upper limit on skyscrapers isn't
really engineering it's more money um
you can build a skyscraper up into the
at least you know
much further up into the atmosphere than
we've successfully built them um
uh it just gets rapidly more expensive
and there's just not a lot of economic
incentive to do that most of the really
tall skyscrapers are sort of built for
bragging rights as much as anything
um but
uh a billion stories is just orders of
magnitude bigger than that and so you'd
end up with a skyscraper that
is far enough out that
as the earth is rotating it's being
flung outward by centrifugal force
harder than gravity is pulling it down
so you end up with a sort of space
elevator situation where suddenly your
problem is not making it
strong against compression it's keeping
it from being flung apart
um and you would also with a billion
stories that's enough that you would
have a problem where the the end of the
skyscraper would be in danger of
swatting against the moon
not the sun not the moon so you'd end up
with a uh with yeah with these fragments
of skyscraper falling and like the even
if it's not that big a building the
amount of energy in
you know a billion you know half a
billion
floors of us building entering the
atmosphere all at once you're going to
get some pretty significant uh
destruction here on earth when the thing
finally falls apart so clearly one of
the skills you have to develop or maybe
you just had this all along is
the research aspect of this right you're
not sitting down with pencil and paper i
mean when you say things like
the limitation on skyscrapers is more
money than engineering
how do you find that out i mean do you
have secrets or is it just like fire up
the google like everybody else
um i think
at some point i've
a useful a useful skill in this kind of
thing is being able to to
skim a lot of different things until you
find something that's promising and then
dig into it
and usually what i'll do is either
you know skim until i like just look
through google
libraries like the the internet archive
has a lot of cool weird old reports on
it um
but really some of the best resources
are just pdfs on some like defunct
government website where the link is
broken but you can find an archive copy
and it was like oh this was briefly
posted in in 2004 and it happens to be
like a report on someone in the 60s who
did this exact thing
um
i really do like the the very practical
questions that don't even like one of
the ones that didn't really require all
that much in the way of of fancy physics
was someone who asked uh she wanted to
know what would happen if
she walked
over uh the stood over the geyser
at old faithful uh in yellowstone
when it erupted sure
and and that's a great question and
it has my favorite quality which is like
i hear it and i'm like oh well i mean of
course you
um
i mean
nothing good but
like would you get flung into the air
right or would it just burn you or what
and so like one of the first things i
did you know i did some some back of the
envelope calculations about like how
much liquid actually comes out of there
in what form is it you know what's the
flow rate what's the speed what's
everything
um but also like has anyone done that
um and so i was looking at like
records of of um
you know injuries around old faithful
the the park service is very clear about
how you should not try to do this
um
and what i learned sort of surprisingly
was
as far as so i found this wonderful book
um uh uh death in yellowstone by the uh
yellowstone park historian that just
kind of catalogs all the different
natural hazards there of which there are
a lot you know everything from like
exposure to rock slides to falls to
lightning quite a bit of that um you
know people who try to feed bears or
take pictures with them um bison
yeah and uh also some regular human
murderers they've got a few of those
there you know like like many places
um but what was interesting going and so
when i'm like looking through research
part of it is
try to find something that has the
answer and this book did indeed have the
answer which is um
that surprisingly no one has as far as i
can tell been killed by the geyser
itself erupting
um
but it's also you find a book cataloging
all of the different injuries that
happen to people in yellowstone
and that's gonna like
even if i don't see the answer i'm
looking for there i'm like wait okay i
want to stop and read this you know like
the chapter indices or like all these
different kinds of injuries and some of
them are things that never even occurred
to me
um and so what i learned is not a lot of
people have been have been uh uh killed
there
a huge number of people have been badly
burned
many of them by leaning over and trying
to look into the geyser when it erupts
when it's like exactly the thing you'd
think
um there's even i think there was a
german uh doctor a tourist who fell in
uh in the 1920s who fell into the little
crevice where it erupts and managed to
get out as it was erupting and was
scalded but uh uh survived so is that
because the water is hot i don't know
much about old people yeah so
so the geysers they're they're erupting
water that's it's really super heated
it's under extreme pressure it's coming
out going you know uh uh on the order of
you know
uh
50 to 100 meters per second i think the
the the amount of momentum carried by
the stream it has pretty low density
it's like you know one of those cotton
candy type
uh fluffy pillow but it's like getting
hit by a pillow going at you know the
speed of a car on the highway right um
if you were if you took a direct hit
from the stream or if you stood over it
with an umbrella or something it could
absolutely fling you very high into the
air okay um
so the probably the fall would get you
before the burns if that happened um but
people do get very badly burned
including um
so the reason that they tell you not to
do this is the then they tell you not to
go near the geyser
is that it is extremely dangerous of
course to get scalded by the geyser but
what the real danger there is around the
geyser there are all these boiling
mineral pools
that are of um you know
like uh just barely on the edge of
boiling water with a mineral crust over
the surface and so if you like are
walking around there
you could step on what looks like rock
and just plunge through into boiling
water wow okay
good safety tip um
there are there are some very harrowing
accounts of accidents that that are kind
of that i i at some point i'm like all
right i've read enough of these i don't
wanna
um but you know you so
so
really what would get you would be
trying to walk toward the uh the geyser
that's where the real danger is and and
so
my big takeaway from reading this is
like if you ever go to yellowstone
they've got railings
just stay behind the railings
that is good advice it's there for a
reason there's a whole book cataloging
why
well and this is a great reminder of why
i'm not very good at exactly the kinds
of questions that you're devoted to
answering here i mean i'm a theoretical
physicist but i think about where the
universe came from and how quantum
mechanics works and the whole art form
there
is simplifying away all the
complications and almost every question
that you answer in the book is about
there's this complication you didn't
think about and that changes what you
might have guessed
yeah and well and i think
it's sort of an interesting question
because when we talk about simplifying
away the complications
we're doing it in the service of
answering a question you know like the
reason you assume a spherical cow in the
in a vacuum as the you know the
physicist expression goes they never say
what is it you're trying to find out
about the cow you know
like you're doing this in the process of
trying to figure out what would the
cow's orbital path be or you know
how much would its mass increase if you
did this to it places where the the
vacuum and the shape don't matter right
um
but like you do have a question you're
trying to answer
and and so a lot of the what if
questions the question is just kind of
broadly what would happen yeah
um
sometimes it's like would this work
would you be able to do this um but in
in every case you know the
simplifications you're making are guided
by like that that question you're trying
to answer you know so i feel like you're
you're doing the same process i think
you know the the
like when you when you're
i don't know when you're when you're
building an inflationary model of the
early universe like
you could just simplify away everything
right you could just be like well
at this time there was the universe we
won't worry about the details but you
don't you you
i think i think uh you're
you're um
you're selling yourself short by saying
you don't address the complications like
it's all complications choosing which
ones you're going to focus on i mean i
guess the everyday world uh you know
dinosaurs and baseball and geysers to
the extent that they're at the everyday
world this is deep within a regime where
the dynamics are complex and non-linear
and strongly coupled to each other and
it's it becomes hard to
you know figure out exactly what matters
and what doesn't like have you ever
answered a question and then had some
expert come along and say like no no you
missed the most important thing
i would say
i have been lucky to mostly avoid
that uh you know that level of of um
you know having someone say oh you've
got this all wrong um i also
will often like
tackle things where i'm like well i'm
pretty sure no one's going to be able to
test this so
who's to say whether i'm wrong about
what would happen if you threw a
battleship into the sun or whatever it
is
um but uh
you know when i and i really i i think i
have an instinct to hedge on things i
like i i really i'm not i'm not just
trying to give a good answer you know
i'm trying to find an answer that
satisfies me
and so
so there are a lot of things where it's
like well i don't know what would happen
here's a reasonable guess here's why you
know and i'll try to be be
you know up front about that when i'm
when i'm really not sure about something
it is fun when i have a question that i
don't
think
is gonna be easy to test and then
someone comes along and tests it
um in my in in my first what if book i
had uh someone had asked about if you
threw a stake
uh into the earth's atmosphere from up
very high up
when it fell in
at hypersonic speed how high should you
drop it if you want it to be perfectly
cooked when it lands
and
and i did a bunch of you know
theoretical calculations about i
so at first i came into this as
you know i have an undergraduate physics
degree and so my instinct was okay i
know about
stagnation temperatures meaning if you
have something flying through the air
it compresses the air in front of it and
the center point reaches a certain
temperature and you can figure out
what's the temperature of the stake
going to be at different points in its
uh descend
and then i start looking up okay how
quickly does heat propagate through meat
like you know these materials like a
steak or a water or you know how do you
approximate it and like if you apply
this much heat at this temperature you
know
how how much will the back of the steak
heat up how much will the center heat up
and and i was really struggling to find
good articles on heat propagation
through flesh you know through
and then and then at some point i had a
moment where i sat back and i was like
wait a minute
and then i like close all the physics
tabs and just open a cookbook yeah i was
gonna say there are people who are
devoted like oh wait there's there's a
different regime a different domain of
expertise where they know a lot about
what happens if you apply different
amounts of heat to a steak
and then it turned out it was very easy
to answer and the answer is that um
your steak would be a style called uh
pittsburgh rare where the it has like a
seared
very edge
but the inside is still like raw
um
but what what was interesting so i put
up my explanation you know i said okay
the steak is gonna probably tumble and i
don't know how a stake would tumble in
hypersonic winds
you know there are some shapes where
there's there's
there are models for this but sort of
large kind of floppy
piece of meat
that's roughly the size and shape of a
steak i couldn't find anything specific
on i said as far as i know no one's put
one of these in a hypersonic wind tunnel
but if you do let me know
um
and you know i had my theory about how
it would heat up and you'd some of it
would ablate and you know break up and
and uh uh
uh be blasted off
i got a i got a letter some years later
from a couple of physicists who
said
hey we had a hypersonic wind tunnel and
we finished all our experiments so uh we
went out to the shop and got some steak
and we decided to try it
and
and it was really cool um
and i would say
i would say that kind of quantitatively
i feel like i i had it about right like
i had the temperatures i had the heating
the surface you know it would heat the
surface not not propagate to the
interior the surface would blacken and
uh eventually you know be vaporized away
i think i didn't appreciate quite how
grisly it would be
i saw some pictures that they sent you
know they had the cool diagrams and
everything but but but
boy a steak that has been heated in this
manner
does not look as appetizing
i was still imagining a steak with like
a nice crisp crust
it looked more like like the edge of a
carpet when it's been worn away
um you know like just frayed bits
sticking off you know
uh i didn't i didn't quite appreciate
how much it would
fragment in an irregular way not going
to replace the cast iron skillet as a
way of uh making this but of course then
that raises all these new questions like
the inside of the wind tunnel after this
experiment
did they get yelled at
how did it smell
um yeah they did apparently finish that
they're getting their degrees uh that
they were there their dissertation they
were there for their phd work and so
they did apparently get to keep using
the wind tunnel
well it is one of the things i was going
to get to this later but you bring it up
right now which is that
you're not
aiming i guess at the middle of the
population distribution in terms of your
audience uh but because of the internet
etc because of the you know way you can
reach tiny minorities of people you can
aim at those kind of people you know the
the the geeky
inquisitive physicists who are going to
say like yes this does sound like fun
and you found enough of them to
uh
build up quite a big audience
yeah and i mean it's really cool to to
you know be able to to
come up with my answers and then you
know and then find out
like oh this expert uh uh
is able to
to
answer it better you know has some some
data that i didn't have it's it's i
think that the the neatest effect for of
that has been that
it's made me feel like oh now i have a
book i'm writing it's being reaching a
real audience i can sort of feel
justified in going and bothering someone
who oh yeah like the people sending me
questions you know when i started out
you know who i just sort of assume oh
but they have something important to do
i shouldn't bother them about this
um and what i found is like reaching out
to scientists is like
they're really
nice like
they're
some of them you know even and
even if they aren't familiar with my my
books or comics or whatever it's like
people are just excited to talk about
the things they work on that's true you
know yeah and so like
like these silly questions they'll
they'll be like oh yeah you know we've
we've i've wondered about that too
here's the answer you know here or or
like
sometimes it's like that's a ridiculous
question but they're like oh it's a
ridiculous question because of this cool
thing you don't know about you know
um
and and so i feel like it's always it's
always a really fun conversation i've
always had it's it's just been really
cool to reach out to people who
who who know stuff directly as sort of a
supplement to like
reading all the stuff they've written
and published it's why i started a
podcast i completely agree like now i
feel licensed to talk to whoever i want
to about all this cool stuff oh it's so
much fun well and i i i don't know it's
and it's cool writing a book and then
getting to talk to people who who
do cool science stuff and then podcasts
uh
who
you know it's it's everything i can do
always in these situations not to turn
the interview around and be like okay
but listen tell me more about the early
universe you know tell me more
well you know look i was talking to
daryl mori who is an executive for the
philadelphia 76ers and one of the
leaders of the
analytics and statistics in basketball
movement he was a guest on my podcast
and you could tell like at the end we
were reaching the end of the
conversation he had to like go make a
trade or whatever and he was getting a
little antsy and then i said you didn't
even ask me about dark matter yet and
then we went on for another 20 minutes
when he was asking me questions about
dark matter so you know
you're very empowered to do that if
that's if that's what you want to do but
first
uh i do want to ask about the
there's a certain skill set in picking
out the questions that are asked there's
certainly skills involved in answering
them but then of course uh
sorry in doing the research to get the
right answer but then the third skill
set in presenting the answer in a
compelling way and obviously humor comes
in but also it's a wonderful education
in problem solving i mean do you how
explicit is your intent to walk people
through exactly what you were thinking
to get these kind of answers because
you're very good about giving the answer
right away and then explaining how you
got there
yeah i think the way i i usually
approach it
is not um
like
when people are trying to simplify
things and i think this is especially
something that that
people with a scientific or academic
background struggle with is there like
well
do you want me to talk to my audience
like they're like really slow you know
do you want me to
to like and and they sort of will if you
try to tell them to simplify things
they'll like really start condescending
to people
and
and so i try not to do that um
the way i i kind of approach this stuff
is
to
imagine you know i've just spent six
hours
researching with all these dead ends and
random side paths and like uh uh
i have you know 50 tabs of of pdfs open
and
and i've got an answer
and then i think okay if i went back in
time and i was going to tell myself hey
i figured it out
i'm going to save you all that time
what would my cliff note summary be you
know what am i okay here's the stuff
that you need to understand to
understand the answer here's the answer
here's cool stuff that i found in the
way that you're not going to want to
miss you know and i and i try to take
that approach is just like assume the
person is interested in the question
because i was interested in the question
um
now how do i get it across you know
every all the cool stuff that i found in
the minimum time right now in the
uh uh
uh like like i don't i don't i try to
assume um
that the person i'm talking to is has a
lot of other stuff going on in their
life you know they're busy they're
they're interested but they don't have
infinite time to like follow me on all
of my little blind alleys and stuff you
know and so i'm just like what's what's
the cool stuff what are the interesting
parts you know
yeah so you give a little bit of a
flavor of the exploration in there you
know you might think this but then we
have to do that without like if you're
really doing a scientific research
problem there are a lot of dead ends and
you don't need to necessarily bring
everyone down all of your dead ends
yeah and that's
i think um
you know maybe the reason for
some of that showing the process some of
it is because
you know it's cool to show how this
stuff works and it's important to bring
people into science and show them how
you know
how you can use these tools to solve a
problem but i think also another part of
it and i never really thought about this
before but is that like
an explanation that doesn't show
some amount of like
how you got there and why you think
that's satisfactory like just raises
more questions
you know sure
like if you answer a question of
you know what
why is the speed of light what it is and
you're like oh well it's because it's
this over the permittivity of free space
times the permeability of free space you
know
you're like okay well wait now i have
two new questions and you know what are
what are those two things
so like you have to explain like why did
you think that was helpful like why did
you know to go there um
like
what does that concept mean how did it
connect up you know you need to give a
little bit of of
you like figure out like if the person
isn't going to know what that word means
that answer is not going to satisfy them
you know well
it makes me think of you know answers to
math problems that always include a step
like now change variables so that x
equals the hyperbolic cosine of theta
and you're like well
why did i do that like how did i get
there and that little bit of insight
into problem solving i think it's you
know it's it's maybe the most valuable
aspect of the book we don't really need
to know what happens when a baseball
goes at 0.9 the speed of light but the
process of getting there is just
fascinating
yeah yeah and and and
and like the secret is a you know one of
these questions might be like completely
ridiculous
but
the math that you're using is the same
as math that you'd use to answer a a
very practical and important question
you know and so like
like you know they're they're
like the thing about the geyser and you
know getting launched up into the air
is
like no one's gonna go and read this
book and you know i certainly hope get
themselves scalded to death by going in
yellowstone no one has ever no one has
ever uh been launched into the air by
yellowstone as far as you know by uh old
faithful as far as we know um
but
uh you know the the equations for like
the way that the gas
flows out of the the mouth of the geyser
um
is
it involves these really cool like
choked flow equations that come up
almost everywhere when you do any kind
of fluid dynamic problems um the the
momentum coming out is like the the the
mass flow you can just use the rocket
equation to figure out what momentum is
being you know uh transferred there
and like all of those are like extremely
common extremely practical extremely
useful mathematical tools and i also
think of the question you got about how
many
how big would google's data centers be
if they were all on punch cards and you
know instantly if you're me your brain
goes well that's not hard figure out you
know how much data is on a punch guard
and how big they are and then you know
multiply it by the size of google's data
center but you don't know what the size
of google's data center is and that was
a fascinating detective story right
yeah yeah it's fun i mean we still don't
they they are not we're very public
about that
um
uh but it um yeah
it's surprising which pieces of
information turn out to be hard to come
by um
like and and and
in that case you know
it was actually really hard to even get
an order of magnitude estimate
you had to be like okay well
like they haven't they could
they've they can only have so many
buildings they don't occupy a majority
of the earth's surface you know right
but they
they they could have enough room to fit
you know okay how many hard drives does
earth manufacture they can't be buying
all of them so like
you know
um you can get you can put bounds from
different directions you can say well
how much power are they using in some
places they have to contract with
municipalities and have public records
of like what power they're consuming
so you can learn something that way and
then you can be like okay how much power
does it take to run
a
server how many drives would be attached
to a server etc um and yeah and you just
kind of keep coming at it from different
directions until you find
kind of something that hems in the
answer to be like oh it's probably in
this range
to this day google uh they did send me a
whole puzzle
with punch cards
that
i had to decode um and and when i
finally did the coded message was no
comment
i think i think i i think you know at
the time that i did that i i feel like i
got it you probably got it right yeah
yeah they would they wouldn't let you
know but they were interested enough to
respond in some way
and
the other part of the the
process that i really really like is and
i think you've mentioned this but
it's not just the most direct
question you could try to answer they're
always tangible right they're always
like something you can touch and
visualize and then put into absurd
situations and and even though like you
say the maybe the equations or the
principles that are involved are common
to other kinds of questions there's
something visceral and and and really uh
connecting about that way of exploring
the the physics and the engineering
behind them
yeah i think um
[Music]
yeah i like i like the really practical
questions that i don't know the answer
to that
like um
someone one of the ones in the in the
book someone asked about uh
about uh what happens
your tires get smaller as you drive them
so
the rubber on the treads
why aren't our roads getting thicker as
a layer of rubber builds up
um where is all that rubber going
and and that it turns out
it turns out it's going everywhere
and
it may be a huge problem and no one
knows how to solve it uh
uh
so i was like
this is an unexpectedly good important
and alarming question yeah um
but then i don't know i i think some of
what's really exciting about this like
with the baseball question um and and
with some of the other ones i got to
tackle in this book is taking something
really extreme and imagining
touching it
i think the single maybe my favorite
question in in what if two if we can
now that we're you know however many
minutes into this podcast i can i can
sneak uh sneak out that that tidbit i
think there's someone who asked about
they said okay the sun it's getting
hotter over time because as it ages at
some point it's going to
you know explode
slash collapse into a white dwarf which
will be extremely hot and then it'll
thermally cool over
uh
through a couple of processes for for
billions of years
so
at what point will it be room
temperature
and can i touch it
like
and and it's
and and that was one where i was like
i had i had i knew in principle that
the white dwarf stars in our universe
are getting are cooling down over time
all of them are still hotter than the
surface of the sun is now you know
they're all in the tens of thousands of
degrees i think because the universe is
not old enough for them to have cooled
but i hadn't until i thought about
someone saying okay so i'm going to go
touch one when is it safe you know
i hadn't i hadn't really thought about
the idea of a room temperature star
right
but like that's gonna happen yeah
and and it's gonna happen in not that
many billion years
like
i was surprised
that like
it's it's it's more than the current age
of the universe but not that much more
it's like in that order of magnitude is
when we'll start getting room
temperature stars interesting
um
and and then i and then i it immediately
raises all these new questions of like
you have a ball that's the size of the
earth
really strong gravity but
so you couldn't visit the surface yeah
because um
it would uh uh it would crush a person
but it's not like a neutron star
it's not gravity so much that no
structure can survive on the surface
you know
you could you could in principle come up
with some kind of a solid-state probe
and and then and then i got to think
about how would you land
okay
um
and and i try in the book to you know
come up with a plan and i can see right
now you've just gotten this look as
you're like
well i mean
okay could you you know
it's like it's like getting a song stuck
in your head you once you hear the
question right it's like your brain will
never be fully engaged in what you're
talking about because in the back of
your mind you're still thinking well
okay could you with a nuclear no what if
you orbit
okay what are the title forces you know
yeah no i'm thinking like how big could
a cube of iron be and still maintain in
structural integrity in that
gravitational field things like that
you can you can have a person-sized one
you can have uh uh
uh you can build some structures uh uh
on on roughly a human scale
of sturdy materials what is the
atmosphere like on a room temperature
neutron star i mean there's probably a
solid surface but then there's something
on top yeah and this is all hypothetical
there's a couple of papers on this um um
[Music]
you don't get the you get some amount of
sort of sorting at the surface from the
the gravity pulling the heavier elements
toward the middle
because of the extreme gravity you don't
have a wispy gas kind of at that low
temperature it's not going to be
um
uh
a free-floating atmosphere for the most
part because it makes sense it's you
know the the individual molecules are
don't have enough kinetic energy to keep
themselves up in the air you know they
they stick down to the surface you might
have a little bit of a hydrogen haze
okay depending on
but um you know
i mean right now the sun has the corona
around it which is extremely hot for
reasons that have never been totally
clear to me or to anyone else for that
matter it's an ongoing problem yeah
yeah and so like i don't know maybe
there'd be something weird going on with
the there are gonna be some intense
magnetic fields here i think uh uh i'm
not totally sure um but you know who
knows what like it's possible you'll get
a bit of a haze
um but then like thinking about the haze
i realized so when i it wasn't until i
sat down to try to draw this scenario
you know i'm thinking about this i'm
picturing a room temperature star
picturing landing on it picturing you
know what would you experience like what
would you encounter but it wasn't until
i drew it
i draw a circle i draw a space i draw
the spaceship i'm like i'll make space
black you know it's the background
and now i've got to draw the star
and normally when you draw a star you're
like well this is bright
but then i realize
it's not it's it's not emitting light
right so you the spaceship will need
headlights
and so i drew the star being and then i
drew a little spaceship and then i drew
like headlights illuminating the star
because you need to be able to see it
yeah it's out in the middle of space
super heavy rock and that
somehow that idea of just like having to
shine a flashlight at a star to see it
really just i cannot quite get that
picture out of my head like that's just
so strange and i and it would never have
occurred to me until i sat down to try
to draw it but like you said it's not a
neutron stars the gravitational field is
not so strong that you have to worry
about the bending of light from the
headlines yeah yeah it's pretty um uh
the light's moving pretty normally um
but
you're still gonna be
getting up to
you know
non-survivable speeds as you plunge
toward it uh you know the speeds speeds
where it's like you're gonna start
measuring these speeds in c instead of
uh uh
instead of you know meters per second
good we're getting a lot of good safety
tips here from this podcast conversation
it's very practical yeah
yeah yeah
it's um
you you definitely if you approach the
star to within the distance of the sun's
current surface
that's around the point at which
you're now too late to turn around and
escape
uh not because of you know black hole
style like there's nothing to physically
escape but that's the point at which the
acceleration it's gonna take
is gonna like flatten you to the floor
of your spaceship
good to know so now at that point you'd
better have figured out so like if
you're going to try to do this you've
got to figure out the landing plan
before you get to that point because at
that point you're committed
so this i mean this leads me into
something that is a common question to
both you know the book and and other
books you've written
and xkcd the the comic which is there's
sort of a
it's quirky right i mean your comic is
not the same as uh dunesbury or peanuts
or whatever there's something different
about it and sometimes there's not even
a punch line oftentimes there's not even
a punch line it's just pure
here's something cool or here's
something to think about uh how explicit
is the balance that you have there do
you have to remind yourself well i need
to throw some jokes in to keep the
audience happy or is it just like you go
with what is cool to you and hope the
audience comes along
um
i think i mean i think it's definitely
you know go with what's cool to me part
of it is like
like if i'm gonna
if i'm gonna
post a comic if i'm gonna write
something you know not i
i think that that
you can only go so far analyzing this
stuff before you kind of
if you if you think about tying your
shoes too hard you stop being able to do
it
um
so i never i don't know i i think i
think that to the extent that
that i try to balance it it's mostly
like i just think like i'm going to show
this to someone
so
i want to make it worth their time
either there's a good punch line at the
end or there's something so cool and
interesting that they're not worried
about a punchline you know they're like
i just don't want them to be finished
and be like okay why did i read that you
know um
you know so that's why i just try to
think like if i if i have a really cool
way to visualize something
you know
i feel like that'll speak for itself um
and then sometimes you can put in some
jokes here and there too just to make
people make it clear people don't have
to be studying this you know
uh but i think sometimes that's the
punch line isn't even the destination
it's just the thing that reassures you
that we're all just hanging out here
this is fun yeah but i mean there's
definitely sometimes it is like just
purely a really cool infographic right i
mean i think of like the the lord of the
rings characters talking to each other
or the money uh plot uh
or whatever i mean it's just there's
like you say there's little jokes in
there
but it's just thinking about things in a
slightly different way
yeah yeah i mean that's it's that's one
of the things that's the most fun about
this job is being able to um
kind of just decide what it is i'm going
to be doing today you know like what
this uh with each comic uh
you know it's just it has to be
something i think is good and i think
people will like and i get to explore
you know if i'm really interested in
this
this particular idea or this particular
thing but a lot of those really big
charts
um and you know that kind of comic where
i'm like
visualizing something or cataloging
something it's like
it started off as just my notes to
myself you know i'm just trying to
understand this thing and i'm like okay
wait there are too many different
numbers here i need to write them all
down you know
i need to put them in some visual form
so i can like make sense of them
and then like i'll do that and i'll be
like oh i wonder how this other thing
compares to that and i'll go add that in
and then before i know it it's become
this like sprawling uh uh catalog
at what point in this process because
you originally or at some point you were
just working for nasa before you started
xkcd at what point did you realize that
dawn to you like i'm an artist that is
my job
i don't i don't know i i've always i
always feel a little
uh
it always it's always a little bit
strange when people will get really
weird about
about
titles or
or um
you know like defining whether or not
something is art
or or defining you know whether or not
you count as an author or if you're a
and like i can see
[Music]
sometimes if you're
um
you know trying to establish your
legitimacy
um
yeah and that peop you know you have a
right to be taken seriously
like i i i would say i get called
dr monroe
a surprising with surprising frequency
and
i i don't worry about what name people
are using for me but that one does
bother me just because of how many
women i know
you know they do have a phd yeah and so
that that makes me want to be picky
about that sure um
but you know that's just
so like with like people are like oh is
this is this art or not are these comics
or not are you an artist um and i know
that's not not quite what you're asking
there but it but it is something like i
know that when um there's another comic
dinosaur comics that started around you
know at the same time i did where it's
the same six panels every day just new
dialogue same six pictures of dinosaurs
and it's you know clip art
and people spend a lot of time trying to
decide does is this
is this really
a comic or not and i'm like i don't i
don't know no
so who cares about it
exactly but i guess but nevertheless
since you're not just using clip art you
do
whatever the labels are whatever the
legitimacy is you need to make artistic
decisions right like yeah using stick
figures uh there's a sense there's there
are questions about how expressive you
can make stick figures or is it a
limitation or you know like how do you
do you
i'm not quite even sure what that the
question to ask is but how do you
approach the craft of you know you're
trying to say something funny or
illustrate something cool but you're
also drawing it right and you know that
has to come into the best way to do it
yeah um i don't know i don't know if i
have a satisfying answer to that it's um
oh i guess
a lot of trial and error i read a lot of
comics growing up um okay i you know i
one thing i found surprisingly helpful
so i haven't
as as someone might guess if they were
inclined to be judgmental i haven't
taken any art classes
um i did take a technical drafting class
at one point and that ended up being
really helpful um and i sort of think
my my
one of my uh
small opinions
is i feel like anyone who does physics
should have to take a class in
perspective drawing
[Music]
just for the part on where you're
drawing on the board okay you've got the
plane of the so-and-so you know you've
got the particle moving in this plane
and then perpendicular to it you have
this force and now you have another
surface here and i just have so many
memories of of of my physics professors
drawing me like draw the front face of a
cube and then the back face with a
different angle and then they've got
this like picasso like construct and i'm
like
okay i
you know
this is the one thing where like it
would be so helpful it's it's really
helpful to be able to take uh uh
a picture and just figure out like where
do these lines roughly go right um
i think that's helpful like outside of
comics you know it's helpful it's
helpful in in physics it's one of those
one of those places where i think the uh
the
the art can have like very small kind of
communicationy way uh inform
the actual process of the science well
and also we seem to be
i mean i guess i should phrase this as a
question
um
are we still in sort of a dynamical
discovery kind of phase in the history
of web comics like they're clearly a
different thing uh you can use them in
different ways dinosaur comics is
something that probably would never have
gotten a lot of
uh
daily strip use in newspapers back in
the day and then also you can use the
technology in fun ways which you've done
in a couple of xkcd strips so um
are we
have we have we tapped that out or is
there like a whole new frontier we
haven't explored yet
i i don't know um
i i
i feel like
it almost turns into a little bit of a
of a categorization question again like
you know we
in all these different mediums we mess
around with like
getting things across
visually with pictures that are grouped
together with words
and you know there are different
conventions and then you lean on the
conventions and and
use that to say things and you subvert
the expectations you
but it's um
but
and like i think
there are always new ways to do that
with new mediums and and
and
it all kind of bleeds into
into itself like
you know
like when i started doing comics
memes were
like
around but kind of a very different
thing
and then they slowly evolved and like
you now get things like
like the distracted boyfriend meme is
just like the one that came to mind
first just now like that it it's similar
to comics
you know you're like you're taking this
picture and assigning things to it it's
like a political it's very political
cartoon you know it's very um
much in that mold
it's is it a web comic i don't know i
don't know
that
that's one of those things like i don't
i don't really care that much and it's
all
you can call it
you you can decide how you want to group
it and categorize it but it's like it's
a cool way to to get across a point
using these tools and
you know yeah i think that's i think
that's neat and fun
and that's exactly the way that i would
go i mean forgetting about the
categorization ahead of time let's let
the thing be what it is and see how it
evolves into and maybe we'll discover
some new things i mean you
you i would imagine that you do more
programming and scripting than the
typical cartoonist
yeah yeah i think that's probably a safe
bet um
i mean although
a surprising amount of it is like part
of the writing process
um
like like most of the interactive stuff
almost anything that you interact with
um in code
i i've worked with someone who you know
did who who does javascript who handles
that better like anything's gonna be
public facing like that what i'll do is
programming like
for
there was a comment a while ago that was
wikipedia article titles that you can
sing to the tune of teenage mutant ninja
turtles
okay um
ace ventura pet detective single-payer
health insurance
you know you can sing it to the ace
ventura pet detective like the teenage
mutant ninja turtles theme uh
and
and so i made a whole list of these
but it's not just any like
eight syllable you know any word with
like the right number of
syllables
syllables
you have to have the right patterns of
stress
right
and like
that's actually kind of tricky so i like
got like a language processing library
figured out how to use it figured out
how to get like extract syllable
patterns from words and stress patterns
which meant i had to learn how to
interpret those like it was they have a
whole like system for this
and then
get something download all of
wikipedia's articles run them through
this generate a list of candidates you
know filter through it
like most of the work there was just the
programming
you know most of the work there was was
learning how to use that software and it
was just because i wanted to make this
joke about because i had noticed one or
two articles that you could sing to that
how many titles are there
um
the the
i ended up publishing a comic that was
mostly just a list of them you know
which had a few dozen uh you know maybe
100 the
the total number of our of articles that
technically qualify i think is probably
in the maybe tens of thousands maybe
thousands okay so you picked out your
favorites for the comic yeah so i could
skim through and find find the ones that
that work the best there is something
about
the
again this is a very vague kind of
question which maybe there's no answer
to but
there's something about the style of
xkcd where uh you know you put your
fingers on things that are pretty
familiar to a certain segment of people
right there's a reason why people say
there's the next kcd for everything and
a lot of scientists and engineers have
xkcd's on their doors and so forth uh so
the impossible to answer question is you
know like how do you distill these
little
bits of truth down to a comic or you
know how do you how do you
put your finger on these things that
everyone goes oh yes right someone is
wrong on the internet i
i i have spent that night
uh man i don't i that's another i don't
know i i think about the stuff that that
i have strong feelings about and or that
i notice and then i think
you know what is this is this uh is this
a common thing but like it's not always
about just like i'm gonna try to find
something relatable or you know i'm
gonna
i'm gonna i wonder if this is a
universal experience some of the you
know the the comic that you just
mentioned about
like
someone is wrong on the internet
where i did this comic about this
phenomenon of like not not being able to
drop something because there's someone
out there who has a wrong opinion and
you need to correct it you know they're
wrong about something um i partly drew
that one just trying to call myself out
like of course
it's like i catch myself doing this okay
i'm gonna do a whole comic about it um
and that will both serve to you know
just drawing it and making it explicit
like it's a reminder to myself like oh
yeah this is a thing that's easy to get
sucked into and i should back off you
know i should remember not to not to get
too caught up in wanting to correct
someone
but also
it worked extra well
because let me tell you nothing takes
the wind out of your sails then you make
thinking you're making a really good
point and then someone else quoting your
own comic back at you oh yeah okay so
now i have to be careful not to not to
go too overboard and correcting people
because they'll just reply with a link
to my own comic
uh do you i mean do you have to like
index all the comics you've ever done to
make sure that you're not telling the
same joke multiple times
definitely i mean but i have that
problem in real life like i'll tell a
story i'll have like a really good
little story you like you forget which
it's like you have to keep a table of
which of your friends you've told the
cool microwave story too it's terrible
and and otherwise you start into it and
they're like yes we know this one you
you told us last winter and also at the
party before that
is there do you feel different like when
you're doing the comic versus a book um
like
what if uh i mean the comic is supposed
to be
presumably mostly entertaining and the
book maybe is mostly informative or is
it just whatever is working in the
moment
um i think i think when i'm
writing
what if i have a goal which is i want to
get
i want to get the answer
you know and with the comic it's a lot
more like i have to show why i
introduced this topic
like you you can't you you can have a a
any kind of a sketch or a movie or a
show you open with a something happening
and you start watching me like all right
i trust you're going somewhere with that
um
and and so you have to then have
something to make it worth their while
with um
with what if it's like i open with the
question now we're all on the same page
about where this is supposed to end you
know like we want to know the answer
now the question is like
what's the route to get there and what's
the weird stuff along the way so i guess
it's almost like an episodic versus long
arc kind of storytelling like you know
you have the buy-in from the audience
presumably if they bought a book called
what if they know what they're expecting
but in the comic every every
week is it that you put up a new comic
um it's uh three times a week three
times a week yeah so that yeah so you
have to sort of reestablish
a uh premise and get to the punch line
in a very short number of words right
yeah yeah it's it man nothing will make
you
edit yourself down like especially i
mean that's i handwrite the text in my
comics
and
and yeah nothing
having to actually write out all those
words really makes you realize how much
how many how many words you've written
that's that's one way to keep your word
count down
but your handwriting is very good i
wonder if that's possibly uh part of the
drafting class you took because i also
took a drafting class and the only thing
it did was improve my printing
yeah no i i think handwriting was the
first class i got a bad grade in yeah
like you you reach the point at which
they start giving you grades or marks
and and
and you know and then a year into that
uh
i think i got my first you know c or d
or something in the handwriting class
and i was like okay well i'll just
accept that handwriting isn't my strong
suit um and then you know i went on to
get many other c's and d's
but i
uh it is funny that that's the career i
ended up in was i do more hand lettering
than almost any other job nowadays
but maybe this is a i mean a good place
to wind up because you know joking about
not getting good grades in school but
look there's no
super strong correlation between getting
good grades in school and being good at
things
there's a kind of thing you can be good
at that requires that you get good
grades in school but you know you have
been able to find a niche for doing
something that you're very very good at
even though the whole job you have
literally didn't exist when you were
born right you didn't grow up wanting to
be a web cartoonist so uh is there any
is there any
lesson here that we could get is there
anything that you can uh you know think
about about um
finding a way to
get your talents into useful
channels
uh for the vast listenership out here
out there
i don't i don't know i feel like it's
always tough to ask someone who's
like
you know if you get someone who's
successful at something and you're like
okay what advice do you have it's like
you're you're really sampling
from a pool of people that's selected
here you know
it's like if you interview if you only
interview lottery winners and you're
like what's the secret and they're just
like you gotta buy a lot of tickets you
just got to keep buying tickets don't
worry it'll pay off in the end i'm
living proof of that you know so it's
like i don't know i mean i know what
worked for me
but
i don't know
how likely it was to work
you know i know what what i i think that
um
i don't know i think that i
i was lucky in that i just kind of
put put stuff out there
and paid attention to
to what was working what people you know
like like when i originally posted my
comics i wasn't really thinking about
i i didn't think that there would be an
audience for it and then i was surprised
when people started sending some of them
around
and i was like oh this is connecting
with people cool i can do more of these
you know
and i don't know i think there's there's
an amount of like a combination of being
really confident about like hey maybe
someone is interested in this maybe
someone wants to
to do this i'm going to just plow ahead
with this right
i think there's a combination of
being confident about about the things
you're interested in and the things you
think are cool you know the things that
you're excited about and trust that like
there are other that other people
probably share those feelings and also
like being aware of whether or not the
way you're communicating with other
people is working right or not
um
and kind of accept that like i think
this is advice way that goes way beyond
comics or even
creative work
or careers is just like
communicating with people is hard
and so
and like
fundamentally
the only measure of whether you're doing
it right is if other people are getting
the message that you want them to
and so
you kind of have to go into it with this
humility of like
if i say this and people are taking the
wrong thing from it
you know
i can't control everything about how
they feel or i can't take responsibility
for all of that but also
if i'm not getting the response that i
was going for
then what am i doing right like i should
try something different you know if
like we're all just trying to connect
with each other and get on the same page
with each other about all these things
and i think it's
it's good to have sort of a humility
about like
if i use this word and people understand
are understanding me wrong
i can be like well it's because they
don't understand this word it really
means this you know and i can just be
angry all the time or i can be like okay
what words would get this across you
know and i think that going into things
with a little bit of kind of humility
and willingness to self-correct about
that kind of thing is
is
really helpful because otherwise you
just get more and more angry and lonely
yeah look i'm actually quite skeptical
about advice as a genre in many ways
because people's
situations are always very different
from each other but that kind of sort of
general thing to keep in mind uh can be
useful i mean maybe maybe to to end on a
something more concrete um but along the
same veins am i crazy to draw a
connection between things that nasa does
and things that you do i know that you
worked for nasa but in in some ways
nasa is an example of a bunch of people
who are faced with these real world
versions of what-if questions what if we
needed to land a rover on mars without
it crashing right i mean there is some
the the what if questions are great
because they're absurd
but the
there are the lessons that we learn from
them are are actually kind of important
yeah i think something that i really
like something that i think is really
unique
about nasa compared to a lot of the
other you know big places where there's
a lot of interesting technical stuff
going on
is that they're
they are
um tasked with doing things
for no reason except that we think it's
a good idea
like collectively as a society
to
do this to learn more to it it's like
it's like very um you know like there
are benefits from the things nasa does
and a lot of the stuff they do teaches
us about the world which is important
because the world is where we live and
might you know destroy us at any moment
um
so it's it's important to study it it's
you know self-interested in that way but
like finding out
was their life on mars is there life on
mars it's something we want to do we
don't want to do it for a reason we just
want to know like people are curious and
and nasa is just like they are going to
they are working on these problems
because they
want to know and they are acting as you
know
our representatives you know my
representative as you know in
my country to go out there and you know
work with these other space agencies and
and solve these and solve problems that
there's not necessarily an economic
incentive to solve you know or that
there's not
someone who's going to pay for it it's
just like we've all decided we want to
know what's up there on those moons
let's let's pick some people and have
them you know go figure it out
um and i think that's really cool it's
just answering a question because we
want to know the answer and that's uh
i think that's a good thing to do
sometimes and i bet that uh there's some
young people out there who will read
your books and be inspired to do exactly
that so uh i hope that they do buy them
yeah thank you randall monroe thanks
very much for being on the winescape
thanks so much for having me on it was
so much fun to talk to you great take
care you too
[Music]
you